on va accueillir tout de suite la
première relooké c'est isabelle morini
bosc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour avancer
alors attention aux jeunes on peut avoir
une photo d'isabelle moret niveau s'il
vous plaît souper est ce qu'on peut
avoir une photo d'isabelle morini-bosc
quand elle est partie quand elle est
partie s'il vous plaît merci aurélie
c'est juste une petite photo à calais
voilà alors ils sont en train de le
caler il aurait dû le cas les avants
mais voilà c'est la régie revient sur
vous les connaissez bien entendu vous
connaissez la personne alors vous je
vous dire je vous êtes magnifiques comme
ça ne vous aide pas dur puis l'avantagé
cheveux elle était la moitié de la salle
alors est ce qu'on l'a prouvé que cette
photo c'est alors voilà donc regarder
quand vous étiez avoir regardé nous est
belle comme ça aussi
et là c'est complètement autre chose ils
vous ont mis des melons à mon avis deux
permanents mal alors attention vous ne
vous êtes pas vu l maija belle morini
bosc
oui c'est salma hayek oui c'est arrête
tes conneries plus tôt alors vous êtes
magnifique je vous le dis vous allez
avoir un choc mais mettez vous bien
devant le miroir
attention serait mieux si je la prenais
grecque non non non non voilà attention
[Applaudissements]
ayant bien
j'aime beaucoup nous avons besoin mais
je pense que je veux faire nourrissent
mme ça vous plaît ou pas les saints non
d'accord le reste oui tout le reste oui
la coupe ettu la paix rue je rêve
d'avoir des cheveux longs et lisses donc
moi la perruque la passe au salon milieu
de semaine prochaine je m'associe pas
d'accord merci isabelle morini bosc à la
voiture